aquí en el arco del triunfo tuvo lugar
la conmemoración del 11 de noviembre
cuando se rinde homenaje a todas las
personas que dieron su vida por francia
de hecho siete oficiales franceses
perdieron la vida en el último año pero
también fue la oportunidad de rendir un
último homenaje a llama el último
compañero de la liberación quien
falleció hace una mes a sus 101 años
esta orden de la liberación fue creada
por el general de gaulle en
1940 el féretro de iberaval llaman llegó
hasta aquí hasta el arco de triunfo
sobre una tanque de guerra y luego
reposo durante unos instantes justamente
al lado de la de la tumba del soldado
desconocido para maxcom pronunció un
breve discurso de un tono bastante
solemne en el que recordó los valiosos
que habían realizado estas mil 38
personas de la orden de la liberación
civiles militares hombres y mujeres de
varias culturas de varios países que
lucharon por liberar a francia de la
ocupación nazi durante la segunda guerra
durante esta ceremonia pues participaron
cientos de personas aquí en la plaza del
ritual entre los asistentes estaba todo
el gabinete ministerial y entre los
presentes también estaba camada harris
la vicepresidenta de eeuu quien había
querido participar en esta ceremonia
justamente cuando en su país se celebra
el veterano stein